it's great to have back on the program
attorney and co-host of Ring of Fire
Mike Papantonio we are here today to
talk about his new book law and disorder
uh PAP I'm about halfway through the
book I love thrillers of all kinds and
this is a thriller that it doesn't exist
in a completely fictional world sadly
because much of what's in the book
relates to the real state of corporate
power and so many of the other issues
that you work on in your legal practice
talk to us first about the process here
is the idea that it is loosely based
around your work is it talk to us about
that yeah the case is involved in that
book are actual cases that have taken
place but they're they're fictionalized
only to the extent of as you point out
it's a thriller it's the idea is to be
able to to entertain at the same time
tell stories that there's no way on
earth corporate media would ever tell
because their advertisers won't let them
tell the story so what I've done is I've
taken cases that I've actually handled
these are you know we have a specialty
with what I do its handling complex
cases there's only handful of us in the
country that do it there a complex
environmental cases complex and uh
pharmaceutical cases whistleblower cases
those type of Wall Street cases we don't
handle you know auto case it's so the
stuff that we've handled for 35 years is
all complex and they all in themselves
the great stories so what I've done is
taken that David I've put it into a
fiction that for uh fortunately
apparently people like it it's selling
very well in the reviews on it have been
extraordinary yet to call it a
page-turner is definitely an
understatement I mean I I am am riveted
by and in and I already know some of the
stories that are being alluded to order
directly discussed what's your process
here so when you sat down to do this
I've talked to authors who have done
novels where they basically just start
writing at the beginning they just get
into the writing and I know other
authors who chart out the the sort of
story arc in total before they start
actually fleshing it out it what was
your process with this with these kinds
of books there's
have them by the way this is the first
one and there's two more coming on also
very similar kinds of huge complex cases
but that they kind of the stories
written because the case is already
taken place and the I simply take that
and I build the framework around that I
begin it and I'll and the story before I
go too far down the road because the
story the story is actually put together
the difficulty in of course in any
fiction I find is is the narratives have
got to be convincing narratives how do
people really talk what would they
really say in a conversation and so I
think the narrative plug-in is probably
to me I think it's that it's it's it's
probably the most challenging unless you
do it a lot on the news editing major
from University of Florida I was
intended to be a journalist and and
actually work in the area of journalism
but the there's always a discussion if
you can't the idea is show me don't tell
me I know you've heard that before
probably but show me don't tell me is
something that you hear a good trial
lawyers always going to be talking about
don't tell the jury what you want them
to understand show them the picture show
them the document show them where this
all leads and I think in writing i think
in writing a book like this it's
important to show them by way of
dialogue and by way of narratives rather
than just telling the story about a
corporate uh corrupt cut corporation
that killed people and so you can do
that a lot of a lot of different ways i
can only imagine that one of the
difficulties and I'm saying difficulty
sort of tongue-in-cheek is when you talk
about a screenplay or a novel there's
this tendency to not want to create
overly crazy or unbelievable scenarios
because sometimes we hear this phrase
this would not even be believable as a
movie but in some of these cases that
you've actually worked on when it comes
to corporate corruption and the crazy
things that go on behind the scenes it
is almost unbelievable but unfortunately
it's all too real yeah and that's that's
part of the problem that's why the books
like this are important David a grisham
I thought did
really good job especially first started
writing telling stories that there's no
way that corporate media or newspapers
are going to tell you they can't their
advertisers won't let them and so
sometimes when you run a story light for
example in that particular book way I
talk about a pharmaceutical that kills
young women between 18 and 35 it's a
birth control well I remember calling
the media about that once we started
seeing that trend and i would call i
would call NBC or CBS or one of the one
of the folks we had our PR people doing
that and it was they didn't believe the
story and it wasn't clear to me whether
they didn't run the story that would
have saved hundreds of lives had they
gone ahead and done what we asked them
to do and that is to publicize the story
it would have started it would have
saved hundreds of lives it wasn't clear
to me whether they advertiser wouldn't
let them do that or whether the story
simply sounded so remarkable that they
didn't believe it was true but it was
true and all of these stories it will be
told in these three books are true and I
want to be very clear I don't I don't I
put barnacles on lawyers where barnacles
have to be there in the next book for
example I really go after a handful of
plaintiffs lawyers claim it's lawyers
that I think are doing such a disservice
to democracy in the way that they're you
know it's almost like wholesale practice
of law and it's killing it's killing the
process and so I go after them I go
after judges that that understand
clearly that they're not really judges
they're really politicians with black
robes that simply are reflecting their
ideology rather than making judicial
kinds of decision I go after the
industry regulators look there's so many
stories to tell and that's why I thought
it was necessary to have three books to
tell all of the stories and they're all
they're all about different cases but
they all tell stories that there is no
way on earth there is no way on earth
the average reader would know about
these stories without reading a book
like this well people who are more
familiar with number one some of the
people associated with your law firm
number to some of these cases as
they read the book they'll recognize
some of the names I know there's a
character named david pakman but there's
also other characters where the names
have been changed a little bit more and
to that end are there people that you've
heard from or directly or indirectly who
are not pleased with some of what is
being described in this book because you
are telling a lot I haven't heard from
them but some of them I was pretty
unkind to and I'm sure they're not going
to be pleased but if they're not pleased
with this one get ready for the second
one the truth is you have to tell these
stories I think it's really wrong for
fiction writer 22 to use that fiction
edge and and somehow bury the truth I
mean it that every story has some truth
okay it is not the truth about what
happened a B and C but what is the truth
about the theme the theme of what
occurred in a B and C and I think you
have to be truthful with yourself when
you see somebody in your own business
doing something wrong you got to talk
about it you have to take the risk and
you have to talk about a federal judge
who slept through a or in this case that
they they make a ruling without any
knowledge of what they just heard or
regulator with the EPA or FDA that we
know is nothing more than a
pharmaceutical pimp a corporate pimp
doing nothing but pimping for industry
you have to talk about those stories in
fiction just like you would in any
narrative that you might do day to day
you tell you tell real stories these are
real stories David but they're just
dressed up in a way that it's a fiction
last thing I want to ask about and this
is completely just me being interested
in the process here you had a situation
where because you're fictionalizing real
cases like you said a lot of it is sort
of written by the reality of the cases
but what were the biggest changes in the
book from the maybe the first draft to
what ultimately ended up being published
where they character changes were they
including or removing certain parts I
mean what were the biggest change the
biggest thing is the removal the most
difficult thing is fortunately I had
great editors I had wonder
editor's and at the end of it I would
look at something that's left on the
floor and I'd say gee I really like that
you know I thought it was really
important but what you have to do you
have to have truth you have to be
truthful with yourself about what the
editor is trying to say and in a fiction
the key is to turn the page you're not
writing in missioner novel where he's
talking about everything you want to
know about it a pineapple you know
everything you want to know about a
particular item mr. was wonderful about
that but it's not it's not fiction it's
not doesn't it's not a it's not a
page-turner and so the difficulty I
think for any fiction writer if they
have a good editor is saying you know
what you really know what you're doing
I'm gonna go with you on this will drop
that scene from the book can move on the
book is law and disorder we've been
speaking with the book's author attorney
and ring of fire co host Mike Papantonio
you can of course get the book through
our recommendations page at david
pakman.com and also using the link in
the description to this video if you're
watching on youtube uh pap I'm enjoying
it thanks so much for talking to us
about it thank you David